libérez la libérer maria notre oeil ou
les slogans ont circulé dans les rues de
minsk
une foule en colère qui dénoncent la
disparition d'une des dernières figures
de proue de l'opposition qui étaient
encore en liberté
pas plus tard que dimanche maria colline
escobar they même ne pas craindre pour
sa sécurité
non un autre le lendemain elle été
appréhendé par des hommes masqués
les autorités du bélarus ont même tenté
de faire croire en publiant cette vidéo
qu'elle avait fui en ukraine mais c'est
complètement faux on a plutôt essayé de
l'expulser de force et elle a
courageusement résisté et même déchiré
son passeport a compté collègues qui ont
été amenées avec elle à la frontière et
qui eux ont été forcées de traverser en
ukraine sous peine de menaces du régime
de loukachenko
loukachenko qui s'accroche au pouvoir
dans cette rare entrevue avec la chaîne
russia today
il s'est dit indispensable sans moi
c'est tout le pays qui va s'effondrer
et vous savez quoi la russie sera la
prochaine dit loukachenko qui est
attendu au kremlin sous peu une
situation qui est très préoccupante
c'est pour ça que le canada tente de
jouer un rôle au brain d'opposition pour
permettre un dialogue avec le régime de
loukachenko
mais la disparition de maria kolesnikova
qui serait toujours en détention
augure mal pour la suite des choses oui
je suis inquiet et non seulement le
canada mais plusieurs autres pays alors
je pense pas que nous on a demandé sa
mise en liberté médias
mais avec ou sans elle il est de plus en
plus clair que le soulèvement populaire
est là pour rester à des scènes à leeds
merkel à munich affirme des choses
pour autant malgré la répression et la
violence
le peuple n'a pas dit son dernier mot
ici tu as marre alter escaut radio
canada